vice president kamala harris says the
biden administration remains focused on
the root causes of
illegal immigration she was making her
first trip to the southern border since
harris
was assigned the lead to the lead to
respond to an increase in migration
along the border there she visited a
customs and border protection facility
in texas on friday
went to a port of entry and met with
community leaders in el paso
our administration is important to be
clear
is working to build a fair and a
functional and a humane immigration
system
we feel very strongly about that and as
you know we inherited a tough situation
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas joins us now
accompanied harris on the trip good
morning to you mr secretary
we just heard the vice president say
that the administration
inherited a tough situation what was
that situation as you saw it on friday
uh good morning and thank you for having
me uh let me at the outset
uh comment on the tragedy and serve side
i just watched your reporting and our
hearts go out uh to the victims of that
tragic event
the president has declared an emergency
i spoke late yesterday evening with
dhs's
fema director deanne criswell who was on
scene yesterday and we're
bringing all of the federal resources to
bear to assist our
county state local partners
friday's trip was extremely
successful the vice president had an
opportunity
to see our operations and the full
expanse of them
when we assumed office in january we
inherited
a system that was entirely dismantled
and we've had to rebuild it from scratch
which we are very well underway in doing
mr secretary there's been some
bipartisan
criticism that you visited el paso and
not the rio grande valley where many of
the migrants make the actual crossing
what was behind that decision
well it was my recommendation to visit
el paso el paso is actually one of the
busiest of the nine
sectors across the southwest border and
it also provides the opportunity to see
the full expanse of our work
not only the central processing center
where we encounter migrants bring them
uh to shelter for transfer to
health and human services but we also
were able to visit the port where we
propel
lawful trade and travel through that
port of entry
so we were able to see the full expanse
and
el paso is quite quite busy in fact we
have
encountered just over 113 000
individuals
this fiscal year mr secretary why not
visit
uh fort bliss which is just 10 miles
away and has hundreds of uh
unaccompanied migrant children
reportedly in very difficult conditions
the vice president and the president
directed xavier becerra the secretary of
health and human services
to visit fort bliss which is under his
responsibility and he's doing so
today it was just 10 miles away why not
include it on the vice president's trip
well uh you know we had quite a bit to
see and we were able to
uh meet with the cbp the customs and
border protection
uh personnel both in the central
processing center
and the port of entry the vice president
was
able to meet with migrant children and
understand why
they fled their home in desperation
she was also able to meet with community
members
to understand what they have been
learning from the migrants
who fled the northern triangle countries
of guatemala
honduras and el salvador it was most
instructive and what the president and
vice president have done from the very
outset
is direct their cabinet officials
including me
to address the situation at the border
mr secretary i just want to get a
question in on title 42 that's a
trump-era policy
that allows the administration to
essentially block
asylum claims from tens of thousands of
single adults
and migrant families your administration
has been looking
to repeal title 42 where does that stand
and if you do
repeal it are you prepared for the
inflow title 42 is not an immigration
policy it is a public health
policy that the centers for disease
control
implements and the cdc as it is commonly
known
will continue title 42 or discontinue it
uh if and when the public health
situation
so dictates it's driven uh by what is in
the best
public health interest of the american
people and you're prepared either way
we are planning this is what we do we
know how to address difficult
situations uh we develop plans we
execute our plans
we have incredible personnel in the
department of homeland security all
right secretary mayorkas thank you very
much